a few videos ago we saw that we could
maximize total utility for our fot given
our five dollar spending by calculating
the marginal utility per dollar for each
incremental dollar we could spend on
each of these Goods and then just for
each dollar maximizing its over first
dollar we got a hundred utility points
per dollar for that first chocolate bar
and that was more than any than the
first fruit so that's where we spent it
and then we got more for the second
chocolate bar than we would have even
for that first pound of fruit so we
spent it there then for the third pound
for the third bar of chocolate and then
it became equal to spend for the for the
first pound of fruit so then we spent
the next two dollars on that first pound
of fruit because the price of fruit were
two dollars what I want to do in this
video is explore what happens when I
change the price of the chocolate bars
what happens to our marginal utility per
dollar over here and what in particular
what happens to the quantity demanded
and if you think about where we're at
what we're doing is we figured out with
one price what was the quantity demanded
we demanded three bars if we change the
price and we get another quantity
demanded we're essentially starting to
plot out our demand curve and we can
actually derive our demand curve from
this information right over here so
let's see how we could do that so let's
now assume let's now assume that our
chocolate bars are two dollars so now
we're going to calculate so this
marginal the marginal utility per dollar
this applies to both of these columns
this is for when it was $1.00 per bar
this is now when it's two dollars per
bar well for that first bar I'm still
getting a hundred points of marginal
utility but now it's two dollars so one
hundred divided by two 100 divided by
two is going to give me 50 marginal
utility points per dollar then for that
next bar I'm going to I get eighty
marginal utility points I'm still
enjoying it but enjoying it a little bit
less but I'm paying two dollars for it
so I'm getting eighty divided by two is
forty points when you know and I'm just
giving these arbitrary units forty
points per dollar then the third bar is
thirty points per dollar then the fourth
bar the fourth bar is twenty points per
dollar
now how would I spend my $5 so let me do
this a little bit let me do it over here
so how would I spend my $5 now so my
first dollar where would I get the most
marginal utility per dollar where would
I get the most bang for my buck so my
very first dollar I can either buy half
a bar here I could buy half a bar here
and I'm assuming that for the sake of
for the sake of simplicity let's assume
that I get the same marginal utility per
dollar for the first half a bar and for
the first bar that is kind of constant
until I get to one entire bar and that's
also true for and even if I buy a
fraction of the pound here
so my first dollar I can't use these
numbers this is when the bars roll a
dollar per bar now they're two dollars
per bar this is the reality so now
actually it makes sense for me to at
least for that first dollar I can buy a
half pound of my fruit at a marginal
utility per dollar of 60 so I will buy
my first dollar will go towards 0.5
pounds 0.5 pounds of fruit of fruit and
I'm getting a marginal utility per
dollar of 60 now whereas my second
dollar going to go my second dollar is
going to go well I can still get another
half pound out at a marginal utility of
60 I can't remember we have to ignore
this right here for the sake of this
argument or for the sake of this
scenario right now so I can still get
another half pound for marginal utility
per dollar of 60 so now I buy another I
buy another half pound of fruit and I my
marginal utility per dollar is 60 now
where is where is my third dollar my
third dollar going to be spent well I
could spend it now on I could spend it
now at a rate of $1.00 per 1/2 bar or $2
per bar for chocolate or $1 per 1/2 bar
two dollars per bar for fruit over here
so I'm actually neutral so I could spend
it
let me just for the sake of fun say
let's submit it on 1/2
bar of chocolate half a bar of chocolate
and my marginal utility per dollar is
fifty is fifty then my fourth dollar my
fourth dollar once again I could do a
couple of different things here
I could buy another half bar because I
can buy up to a whole bar at this
marginal utility per dollar up to a
whole bar so why do that so I'll buy
another half chocolate bar so now I have
a whole chocolate bar and once again I'm
able to continue buying that at
[Music]
fifty-fifty utility units per dollar and
then my fifth dollar my fifth dollar
over here what would I do with that well
I don't want to buy I don't want to buy
any more chocolate bars because my
marginal utility per dollar of the
chocolate bar because I've exhausted
kind of what I can buy this utility my
this utility per dollar so my marginal
utility per dollar has gone down now but
now I can still buy fruit at that same
50 so now with that dollar since the
fruit is $2.00 per pound I can buy
another half pound of fruit for four at
a marginal utility per dollar rate of 50
so now I buy another another half pound
of fruit at a marginal utility per
dollar of 50 and you can calculate the
whole the entire the the total of
marginal utility I got this is a
marginal utility per dollar and this is
and this is a dollar spent at that
marginal utility per dollar so my total
mard my total utility I should say the
marginal utility is the increment but my
total utility now is 60 plus 60 is 120
plus 50 plus 50 plus 50 so it's one 120
plus 150 is equal to 270 total utility
total utility but even more interesting
here let's think about the quantity of
chocolate bars that I have now bought
once the price has gone up I have now
bought exactly one chocolate bar so you
could say my third and fourth dollars
were spent on one bar right over here I
bought one bar so let's think about it
all else equal remember ceteris paribus
so we haven't changed the price of fruit
we haven't changed consumer preferences
which
would have changed your marginal utility
numbers right over here all else equals
what happened just when we change the
price of chocolate bars and let me write
it down so if we just just think about
chocolate so if we just think about
chocolate bars
so let me write price and quantity when
the price was $1 when the price was $1
the quantity demanded the quantity
demanded was 50 sighs the quantity
demanded was three bars that was the
first video we saw on marginal utility
we demanded three bars now when the
price now when the price is has gone up
to $2 the quantity demanded is exactly
one bar is exactly one bar and we could
do it everything in between we could we
could see what happens if the price was
a dollar fifty or if the price was fifty
cents if we actually lowered the price
we would see how the how the and there
might actually be a situation where you
would have to have higher quantities
here especially when you lower the price
but by doing that you can you can just
using the assuming you have enough rows
here and we might not have it if you
lower the price but assuming you have
the marginal utility at different
quantities for the two Goods you can
figure out exactly how much chocolate
someone would buy given different
changes in price so we at least have two
points for the demand curve now so if we
assume that this is price and this is
quantity right over here when the price
was $1 the quantity demanded was three
and when the price is $2 the quantity
demanded the quantity demanded is one so
there we have two points we have two
points for our demand curve so our
demand curve might look something might
look something like that but this is all
the if it was linear it would go
straight it would go something straight
like that but we at least have two
points on the curve and we could keep
trying different prices out using this
information to figure out the exact to
figure out the exact shape of that curve